hola, me llamo Olivia Lanes y bienvenidos de nuevo a Computación Cuántica en Práctica, este es el episodio dos: Quantum
circuits. Vamos a cubrir varios temas en la lección de hoy, pero lo que quiero que te lleves son las siguientes tres cosas: uno, qué son los ordenadores cuánticos de IBM
en realidad, para que tengas al menos una imagen aproximada en tu mente de lo que haces cuando envías un trabajo a uno de ellos a través de la
nube; dos, qué es Qiskit, qué son los Primitives y cómo podemos usarlos para crear y ejecutar Quantum circuits
también hablaremos a alto nivel de los distintos tipos de procesadores cuánticos de IBM disponibles y qué distingue a unos de otros; y tres,
por último, el flujo de trabajo típico que seguimos para ejecutar experimentos a escala, que incluye seleccionar los mejores Primitives
para tu caso de uso, mapear un problema a un Quantum circuit y aplicar supresión y mitigación de errores, lo que nos permite
exprimir al máximo la potencia de estas máquinas. Hay mucha información aquí, pero quédate conmigo
porque pronto lo uniremos todo en el contexto de ejemplos reales. Primero, hablemos brevemente de los qubits y del Hardware cuántico real.
Como experimentalista, te puedo asegurar que es fascinante y que realmente ayuda a conectar los puntos para
visualizar lo que ocurre realmente cuando se envían trabajos a un ordenador cuántico a través de la nube. Los procesadores que
vamos a usar están construidos con qubits transmon superconductores. Así es como se ve un pequeño procesador cuántico de IBM.
Estos pequeños cuadrados son los qubits en sí, así que hay un total de cinco en este chip. El transmon
es un capacitor y consta de dos placas de metal conectadas en paralelo con un inductor no lineal llamado
unión de Josephson. Pero para ver la unión de Josephson hay que hacer aún más zoom: se crea a partir de dos
capas superpuestas de metal superconductor, y donde las dos piezas se solapan y se tocan está la unión. Una unión de
Josephson es un elemento que se puede usar para crear un átomo artificial con múltiples niveles de energía, y aislamos
los dos niveles de energía más bajos como nuestro estado qubit. Las líneas onduladas representan los resonadores de microondas,
básicamente líneas de transmisión 2D acopladas al qubit. Cuando programamos un gate, eso equivale esencialmente a elegir un
pulso de microondas altamente calibrado, y la frecuencia, amplitud, forma y duración específicas de esos pulsos hacen que el
qubit haga cosas específicas. Las instrucciones para el pulso de microondas van desde tu ordenador a la nube y
luego son leídas e interpretadas por la electrónica de control a temperatura ambiente, que toma esas instrucciones y físicamente
genera los pulsos. Los llamamos pulsos de microondas porque todos están dentro del ancho de banda de frecuencia de microondas,
que es alrededor de 1 GHz. Después de que las cajas de control a temperatura ambiente crean los pulsos, viajan a través de los cables
hacia el refrigerador de dilución y eventualmente a nuestro chip cuántico. La señal entra en los resonadores a través de
un wire bond en estos pads y luego fluye por la línea de transmisión hasta nuestros qubits. Sé que todo esto puede
haber sido algo técnico y estos detalles no son cruciales para entender lo que viene, pero espero que ahora
puedas al menos imaginar el sistema físico con el que estás a punto de interactuar. Entonces, ¿dónde existen estos ordenadores cuánticos
realmente? Pues IBM tiene docenas de ordenadores cuánticos por todo el mundo y recientemente hemos actualizado nuestra flota para
tener únicamente procesadores de más de 100 qubits. Como mencioné en la lección anterior, algunos están ubicados en un
centro de datos cuántico de IBM en el norte del estado de Nueva York. Esos sistemas están desplegados en la nube para el uso de todos, y algunos
son sistemas dedicados on-premise, con toda la electrónica necesaria para que funcionen, y que dan soporte a nuestros socios
en la red IBM Quantum. Ahora hablemos de Qiskit, que es el kit de desarrollo de software open-source de IBM
diseñado para trabajar con ordenadores cuánticos. A partir de ahora me referiré a esto como el SDK de Qiskit. También existe el
ecosistema de Qiskit, que es una colección de software, tutoriales y funciones que se apoyan en o extienden las funcionalidades principales de Qiskit, así como el
runtime de Qiskit, que es un servicio de computación cuántica y un modelo de programación que permite a los usuarios diseñar y ejecutar eficientemente
sus cargas de trabajo cuánticas usando los Primitives de Qiskit. Un Primitive es básicamente un pequeño bloque de construcción que
puedes usar para diseñar circuits más grandes o un trabajo. Los dos Primitives más importantes para nosotros son el
sampler y el estimator, de los que hablaremos con más profundidad en breve. Si todavía no has descargado e instalado el
SDK de Qiskit, no hay mejor momento que ahora. Qiskit 1.0 fue lanzado recientemente y es más eficiente y
estable que nunca. Así que para los que estéis empezando, habéis llegado en el momento perfecto. Para los
que ya estéis familiarizados con Qiskit, tenéis que descargar e instalar la versión más reciente. Recomendamos usar
pip para instalar Qiskit y el runtime de Qiskit, y ejecutarlos a través de un Jupyter notebook en el navegador web de tu elección. También vas a necesitar
instalar Jupyter notebook o Jupyter Lab en caso de que aún no lo hayas hecho. Estas herramientas son todas gratuitas y
puedes tenerlas funcionando en tu propia máquina local sin ningún coste. Asegúrate de añadir Qiskit con las dependencias de la opción de visualización
para que funcione con Jupyter y te permita crear gráficas. También tendrás que configurar un entorno virtual de Python y hay
instrucciones sobre cómo hacerlo en la página de instalación de Qiskit, enlazada aquí. Una vez que te hayas familiarizado con Qiskit y estés
listo para ejecutar trabajos en ordenadores cuánticos reales, tendrás que registrarte en quantum.com y crear un
token de API de IBM Quantum. También hay un enlace aquí para eso. Un tutorial detallado de cómo hacerlo: sigue todas las
instrucciones en nuestra página de documentación como mencioné, o puedes ver el vídeo de instalación de Coding with Qiskit aquí,
ambos enlazados en la descripción. Ahora estamos casi listos para empezar a hablar de Quantum
circuits. Dado que el objetivo de este curso es enseñarte a ti, la audiencia, cómo escalar tus trabajos para ejecutarse a una escala de más de 100
qubits, creo que la forma más constructiva de avanzar es considerar primero el flujo de trabajo general que vamos a seguir, y la forma más fácil de
entender un flujo de trabajo típico de computación cuántica es a través de los patrones de Qiskit. Los patrones de Qiskit son un marco conceptual que permite a los usuarios ejecutar cargas de trabajo cuánticas
implementando ciertos pasos con herramientas modulares. Esto permite que las tareas de computación cuántica sean realizadas por una
infraestructura de computación heterogénea y potente. Estos pasos pueden realizarse como un servicio y pueden
incorporar gestión de recursos, lo que permite una composabilidad perfecta de nuevas capacidades a medida que se desarrollan. Aquí
están los pasos principales, que los usuarios experimentados de Qiskit probablemente ya reconocerán. El primer paso es el mapeo: este paso
formaliza cómo tomamos un problema general en el que estamos interesados y averiguamos cómo mapearlo a un ordenador cuántico
en forma de circuit. A continuación, optimizamos: en este paso usamos el transpiler de Qiskit para enrutar y distribuir el
circuit sobre el Hardware cuántico físico real. Esto incluye traducir los Quantum Gates individuales en secuencias
de operaciones que se ejecutan en el hardware, así como la optimización de la distribución de esos gates. A continuación,
ejecutamos: los Primitives del runtime de Qiskit proporcionan la interfaz al Hardware cuántico de IBM que permite ejecutar el circuit transpilado.
Este paso también incluye el uso de técnicas de supresión y mitigación de errores, que en gran medida pueden abstraerse del usuario. Por último, post-procesamos: en
este paso, los datos del propio procesador cuántico se procesan para proporcionar al usuario resultados útiles sobre el problema original. Básicamente, este paso
engloba cualquier análisis adicional de los datos obtenidos. Ahora estamos listos para hablar de la base de los programas cuánticos,
que son los Quantum circuits. Con suerte ya estás familiarizado con los Quantum circuits, pero en caso de que no sea así, puede que quieras revisar primero la lección
tres, Quantum circuits, que forma parte de Entendiendo la Información y la Computación Cuántica, enlazada abajo. Aquí solo
vamos a hacer un breve repaso. Un Quantum circuit es una red de Quantum gates y mediciones enlazados
por cables que representan los qubits. Los Quantum circuits pueden leerse como partituras musicales, de izquierda a derecha, comenzando en el
tiempo cero, que está todo a la izquierda. Los qubits virtuales, es decir, qubits que aún no han sido asignados a un
qubit físico real en un procesador, se listan en orden creciente de arriba a abajo. Una vez que configuramos nuestro circuit, podemos añadir
gates. Los gates de un solo qubit, como este gate Hadamard de aquí, afectan solo al qubit en cuyo cable están colocados. Los gates de múltiples qubits,
como este CNOT, afectan a dos o más qubits enlazados por el gate. En este ejemplo, el estado del qubit uno cambia
dependiendo del estado en que se encuentre el qubit cero después de aplicar todos los gates, podemos realizar mediciones
que hacen que los resultados se escriban en registros clásicos. Una característica especialmente importante de
un circuit es su profundidad. La profundidad del quantum circuit es el número mínimo de capas de quantum gates ejecutados en
paralelo necesarias para completar el cálculo definido por el circuit. Para ser claros, los quantum gates pueden ejecutarse en
paralelo, es decir, exactamente al mismo tiempo, siempre que no tengan qubits en común. Pero si dos o más
gates actúan sobre los mismos qubits, entonces no podemos ejecutarlos en paralelo; estamos obligados a ejecutarlos uno tras otro, porque los quantum gates tardan tiempo en
implementarse. La profundidad de un circuit corresponde aproximadamente a la cantidad de tiempo que necesitan las computadoras cuánticas para ejecutarlo.
Por eso, conocer la profundidad de un circuit es importante para saber si puede usarse en un dispositivo en particular o no. También nos dirá si tiene
buenas posibilidades de producir un resultado preciso. A continuación, veamos la selección de un procesador cuántico. IBM
ha lanzado recientemente toda una nueva flota de procesadores con más de 100 qubits cada uno, y puedes acceder a quantum.com para ver
a qué procesadores tienes acceso. Los procesadores llevan nombres de aves por ciertas razones, y los distintos logos
representan diferentes tipos de procesadores. Por ejemplo, estos representan procesadores Eagle, y este ícono es una
garza. El nombre de los procesadores específicos también se encuentra en la parte superior; todos llevan nombres de ciudades, aunque eso
no significa necesariamente que el procesador esté ubicado físicamente en esa ciudad. Son solo nombres. El recuento de qubits,
EPPG y CLOPS son también factores que aparecen listados. Repasaremos cada uno de estos.
Qubits: esto es bastante evidente. Qubits es simplemente el número total de qubits disponibles en ese procesador cuántico o
QPU. EPG son las siglas de "errors per layered gate" (errores por gate en capas), que mide el error promedio del proceso de gate en una cadena de capas de
100 qubits. Básicamente, quieres que sea lo más pequeño posible. CLOPS son las siglas de "circuit layer operations per second" (operaciones de capa de circuit por segundo), y
mide cuántas capas de un quantum volume circuit —que es un circuit virtual— puede ejecutar una QPU por unidad de tiempo.
Cuanto mayor sea el número, más rápido podemos calcular. Esto es equivalente a lo que significa FLOPS en la computación clásica. Ahora bien, estas
diferentes métricas pueden ser más o menos importantes según el área de aplicación específica que te interese. A continuación, vamos a hablar a nivel general de
la asignación a quantum circuits. El primer paso es el paso de asignación, que esencialmente responde a la pregunta: ¿cómo
traduzco mi problema en un quantum circuit que pueda ejecutarse en hardware cuántico? Sin duda alguna,
la asignación es un problema difícil y es un área de investigación activa. A veces, simplemente poder tomar un problema computacional
y crear una secuencia de quantum gates que ayude a resolverlo es la parte más difícil. No existe un método infalible
que garantice el éxito, pero hay pautas recomendadas y ejemplos de problemas que ya sabemos cómo
asignar. La primera pauta es dejar que las computadoras clásicas hagan el trabajo en el que son mejores. Las tareas
que son fáciles para las computadoras clásicas probablemente no se beneficiarán de una computadora cuántica. Las computadoras cuánticas son para problemas que son clásicamente difíciles. Por
supuesto, si es tu primera vez usando Qiskit o una computadora cuántica, no te preocupes por encontrar un problema computacionalmente complejo. Divídelo
en problemas más pequeños que puedas aprender a resolver antes de pasar directamente a un proyecto a escala utilitaria. A continuación, traduce los
resultados de tu problema que quieres medir o entender en un problema de valor esperado o de muestreo.
Para la mayoría de los tipos de problemas, esto corresponde esencialmente al cálculo de una función de costo. Una función de costo es una
función específica del problema que define el objetivo del problema como algo que se debe minimizar o maximizar, y puede
usarse para ver qué tan bien se está desempeñando un estado de prueba o solución con respecto a ese objetivo.
Esta noción puede aplicarse a diversas aplicaciones en química, aprendizaje automático, finanzas, optimización, etc.
Ten en cuenta también que el hardware que vas a usar tiene una topología específica. Algunos qubits no están conectados
entre sí y otros sí, y en última instancia tendrás que asignar tu problema a un circuit que represente esto. Los procesadores cuánticos de IBM
usan lo que se llama una topología heavy hex, que equivale básicamente a conexiones de qubits en una red hexagonal, algo
que veremos con más detalle más adelante en el curso. Por ahora, lo más importante a tener en cuenta es que esta etapa requiere
práctica. Necesitas tener un buen entendimiento no solo de tu problema, sino también de las capacidades del hardware cuántico,
y más adelante veremos un ejemplo específico y un caso de uso para ver cómo se puede lograr el mejor
equilibrio. Ahora veamos cómo optimizar un circuit para el hardware que hemos seleccionado. El objetivo general del
paso de optimización es asignar todos los qubits virtuales de nuestro circuit a qubits reales en algún lugar de la
topología del procesador. El objetivo es reducir los errores tanto como sea posible. Para ello, primero debemos
enrutar y distribuir nuestro circuit de manera eficiente. Lo primero que hay que tener en cuenta es que no todos los qubits están conectados, como
ya dije: algunos están realmente alejados entre sí en el chip, por lo que debemos reducir o eliminar las interacciones de larga distancia
siempre que sea posible. Puedes aplicar una secuencia de swap gates entre qubits vecinos para mover información de qubit
por el chip, pero los swap gates son costosos y propensos a errores, por lo que puede haber mejores formas de hacerlo. A continuación, la distribución
y el enrutamiento son procesos iterativos que asignan un qubit virtual de tu circuit a un qubit físico en el
hardware. Puedes hacer esto manualmente, pero también hay herramientas en Qiskit que pueden hacer recomendaciones sobre la distribución física de
qubits basándose en tasas de error aproximadas. A continuación, podemos combinar secuencias de gates de un qubit que actúan sobre el mismo qubit
en gates individuales, y a veces también podemos eliminar gates innecesarios o combinaciones de gates. Por ejemplo,
algunas combinaciones de gates pueden reducirse a combinaciones más simples, y a veces combinaciones de gates incluso
equivalen a un simple operador identidad, por lo que podemos simplemente eliminarlos. Puedes hacer esto automáticamente usando el
transpiler de Qiskit, o puedes hacerlo manualmente, gate por gate, si tienes una buena razón para ello y quieres
tener más control. Una vez que hemos mejorado la distribución del circuit, el enrutamiento y el número de gates, ya sea manualmente o usando el transpiler de Qiskit,
generalmente queremos visualizar nuestro circuit para asegurarnos de que el tiempo de todos los gates tenga sentido. Hay un argumento que puedes indicar en el transpiler para
visualizar la línea de tiempo de tu circuit y verificar que todo esté alineado como esperarías. Ahora hablemos de la supresión de
errores. La supresión de errores se refiere a diversas técnicas que transforman un circuit durante la compilación para minimizar los errores.
Es diferente de la mitigación de errores, que tiene lugar después de que el circuit ya se ha ejecutado, y llegaremos a eso en breve. Las dos formas más comunes de
supresión de errores de las que nos beneficiamos son el desacoplamiento dinámico y el twirling de Pauli. Habrá algunos
detalles técnicos aquí, pero siempre puedes volver a esto más adelante. El primero, el desacoplamiento dinámico, se utiliza para
cancelar efectivamente parte del ruido que afecta al qubit aplicando una serie de gates que en conjunto equivalen a la
operación identidad, como las secuencias XX, cuyo efecto neto es cancelar aproximadamente los canales de ruido que afectan
al qubit. El Pauli twirling es una forma de insertar gates aleatorios para simplificar el ruido promedio. La aleatoriedad ayuda a
evitar que los efectos de diferentes errores se acumulen tan rápido, y también hace que el ruido sea más fácil de caracterizar.
Este método también forma la base de una técnica de mitigación de errores, y lo discutiremos más adelante.
Nuevamente, hay mucha información aquí, y no te preocupes si no todo se asimila de inmediato. Por suerte, gran parte de esto puede hacerse automáticamente usando el transpiler de Qiskit.
La transpilación puede ser complicada, pero es un paso tan crucial para lograr utilidad a escala
que requiere mucha prueba y error para dominarse y obtener los mejores resultados. Ahora quiero hacer una breve
pausa para hablar del transpiler de Qiskit y sus capacidades con un poco más de detalle. Lo haré a un nivel muy general y luego veremos los detalles y
algunos ejemplos más adelante. En general, la transpilación es el proceso de reescribir un circuit de entrada dado para que coincida con
la topología y el dispositivo cuántico específico, y optimizar el circuit para su ejecución y resiliencia frente al ruido. También
reescribe un circuit dado en los basis gates de ese procesador cuántico específico que has seleccionado para usar. Qiskit tiene cuatro
canalizaciones de transpilación integradas y, a menos que ya estés familiarizado con la optimización de Quantum circuit, te recomiendo usar una de esas
canalizaciones integradas. Por defecto, el transpiler incluye estos seis pasos: inicialización,
layout, routing, traducción, optimización y scheduling. La inicialización se refiere a
cualquier paso inicial que se necesita antes de empezar a incorporar el circuit al backend. Esto normalmente implica
desarrollar instrucciones personalizadas y convertir el circuit en gates de uno y dos qubit. La etapa de layout aplica
un mapeo de layout que asigna los qubits virtuales del circuit a los qubits físicos de un backend. El routing se ejecuta después de que se ha aplicado un layout
e inyecta gates como swap gates en el circuit original para hacerlo compatible con la
conectividad del backend. La cuarta etapa es la traducción. En esta etapa, los gates del circuit se traducen al conjunto base del
backend de destino. La siguiente es la optimización. Esta etapa ejecuta el bucle de optimización principal
repetidamente hasta que se cumple una condición, como alcanzar una profundidad objetivo determinada. Tenemos cuatro niveles de optimización diferentes
entre los que podemos elegir. Por último está el scheduling. Esta etapa se encarga de los pasos de scheduling con conciencia de hardware en un
nivel alto. El scheduling puede entenderse como insertar retrasos en el circuit para compensar cualquier tiempo inactivo en los qubits
entre la ejecución de instrucciones. Como dije, hay cuatro niveles de optimización que van del 0 al 3, donde los
niveles de optimización más altos requieren más tiempo y esfuerzo computacional, pero puede que termines con un circuit mejor.
El nivel de optimización cero está pensado para experimentos de caracterización de dispositivos y, como tal, solo mapea el circuit de entrada a
las restricciones del backend de destino. No realiza ninguna optimización. El nivel de optimización tres
dedica el mayor esfuerzo a optimizar el circuit. Sin embargo, como muchas de las técnicas de optimización del
transpiler se basan en heurísticas, dedicar más esfuerzo computacional no siempre resulta en una mejora
en la calidad del circuit de salida. Si esto es de mayor interés, consulta las páginas del transpiler en la documentación de Qiskit enlazada abajo. Ahora estamos listos para hablar sobre la ejecución real de un Quantum circuit.
Los primitivos del Qiskit runtime proporcionan una interfaz al hardware de IBM Quantum y también abstraen
la supresión y mitigación de errores del usuario. El primitivo sampler devuelve la distribución de cuasi-probabilidad o counts
que representan la probabilidad de medir ciertos bit strings de ceros y unos. El primitivo estimator devuelve valores de expectación
de observables que corresponden a cantidades físicas. En un poco más de detalle, el sampler ejecuta el circuit
varias veces en un dispositivo cuántico, realizando mediciones en cada ejecución y construyendo la distribución de probabilidad
a partir de esos bit strings. Cuantas más ejecuciones o shots realice, más precisos serán los resultados,
pero esto requiere más tiempo y los recursos cuánticos necesarios para ejecutarlo. En concreto, calcula la
probabilidad de obtener cada estado de base estándar posible midiendo el estado preparado por el circuit. El estimator de Qiskit
usa un proceso algebraico complejo para estimar el valor de expectación en un dispositivo cuántico real,
descomponiendo el observable en una combinación de otros observables que tienen bases propias conocidas y ejecutando
bajo el capó de los primitivos están las técnicas llamadas mitigación de errores. La mitigación de errores es un término genérico para todo esto y
básicamente se refiere a las técnicas que nos permiten reducir los errores del circuit modelando el ruido del dispositivo en el momento de la
ejecución. Normalmente esto genera una sobrecarga de preprocesamiento cuántico relacionada con el entrenamiento del modelo y una
sobrecarga de posprocesamiento clásico para mitigar errores en los resultados brutos usando un modelo generado. Pero a cambio de esta
sobrecarga, podemos obtener resultados mucho más precisos. Hay múltiples técnicas que podemos implementar para
la mitigación de errores y vamos a repasar tres de ellas con más detalle. Sin embargo, ten en cuenta que esta es un área de
investigación activa, por lo que es probable que se inventen nuevas técnicas y las existentes sigan mejorando. El
nivel de resiliencia aumenta el coste, o en otras palabras, el tiempo que tarda en ejecutarse tu trabajo. Ya dijimos que en
el nivel de resiliencia cero el transpiler no hace realmente nada en tu circuit, pero a partir del nivel de resiliencia uno introduce un método llamado twirled
readout error extinction, o T-Rex para abreviar. Twirled readout error extinction usa pauli twirling para
mitigar el ruido, algo que ya hemos mencionado. Es una técnica muy general y efectiva que,
hablando intuitivamente, hace que el ruido sea menos irregular y más fácil de manejar. A partir del nivel de resiliencia dos,
introducimos la extrapolación de ruido cero, o ZNE para abreviar. Es una técnica popular con la que recientemente hemos tenido mucho
éxito. La idea detrás de ZNE puede ser un poco sorprendente: en realidad añadimos
ruido adicional encima del que ya existe, pero lo que esto nos permite es extrapolar en la dirección inversa para
predecir cómo serían los resultados si hubiera menos ruido. Esto se puede hacer de varias formas específicas; por ejemplo,
podemos alargar los gates para hacerlos más largos y así más propensos a errores, o podemos ejecutar más gates que en última instancia
resulten en una operación identidad, de modo que el circuit no cambie funcionalmente, pero muestreamos más
ruido de forma deliberada. Eso sí, tienes que hacer esto para cada circuit y cada valor de expectación del que quieras hacer seguimiento, así que
puedes ver cómo puede acabar siendo muy costoso en términos del tiempo requerido. Un tipo específico de ZNE se llama
amplificación de errores probabilística, PEA para abreviar. Una vez que hemos aprendido un modelo de ruido para un gate, PEA funciona muestreando
errores de ese modelo de ruido e inyectándolos deliberadamente en el circuit. Como mencioné, muchas técnicas nuevas
siguen desarrollándose y con suerte se implementarán a medida que veamos más y más aparecer. Hay solo una forma final de
mitigación de errores de la que quiero hablar, llamada cancelación probabilística de errores. En lugar de estar en el tercer nivel de resiliencia,
PEC es una capacidad especial que tienes que activar manualmente en Qiskit porque los recursos computacionales
necesarios para ella no escalan muy bien en comparación con las otras técnicas de mitigación de errores que hemos discutido.
Empiezas aprendiendo sobre el ruido que afecta a tu circuit ejecutando circuitos de aprendizaje de ruido o caracterización de ruido
para cada capa única de gates de dos qubit que están en tu circuit. Estos resultados te permiten describir el ruido
en términos de operadores de Pauli. Una vez que conoces estos términos de ruido, puedes modificar tus circuits para que
tengan efectivamente los PEC opuestos incorporados para cancelar estos canales de ruido. En cierto modo, este proceso es
similar al de los auriculares con cancelación de ruido. Sin embargo, esta forma de deshacer el ruido es muy costosa, con un tiempo de
ejecución que crece exponencialmente con el número de gates, por lo que puede que no sea la mejor opción para un circuit muy grande. Hemos
llegado ahora a la etapa final: el posprocesamiento. Al final, si has hecho un buen trabajo y empleado técnicas adecuadas de mitigación de errores,
puede que veas tu respuesta final cambiar, como en esta figura. Aquí, una distribución sin mitigar
mostrada en morado está bastante lejos del valor esperado real mostrado aquí por esta línea. Sin embargo, una vez que aplicamos nuestra
mitigación de errores, obtenemos una distribución mitigada mostrada aquí en azul, que alcanza su pico mucho más cerca del valor real. Ahora bien,
todo esto tiene un coste y aquí podemos ver que la varianza, o el ancho de la distribución, aumenta, lo cual
no es en general lo que quieres. Pero todo tiene un coste. Por suerte, podemos compensarlo ejecutando más
shots, lo que hace que la distribución se contraiga de vuelta a un nivel aceptable de incertidumbre. Y eso es todo por esta
lección. Para la próxima vez, vamos a tomar todos estos pasos, juntarlos y trabajar en un área y en un ejemplo
de interés de aplicación real. Hay algunas cosas que te recomiendo hacer hasta entonces. Si aún no lo has hecho,
asegúrate de descargar y configurar Qiskit 1.0. También puedes ver la lección asociada a este capítulo y
el episodio anterior en la plataforma de aprendizaje de IBM Quantum. Y por último, si te interesa profundizar más y
aprender más sobre las técnicas de mitigación de errores, consulta una de las numerosas fuentes que he enlazado abajo. Hasta entonces, nos vemos la próxima vez.
[Música]